Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is
going to be my new justice league snyder cut
in batman video zack snyder did a live stream
with a bunch of fans revealing a bunch of new big
dc movies that he has plans for so i'll explain
what's going on the easter eggs and how it all
fits into the timeline if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we're doing a new amazon giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and let me
know what kind of new dc movies you want zack
snyder to work on so just starting with the big
stuff if you didn't see it earlier this week zack
snyder did a new live stream with a bunch of fans
talking about some new big dc movies that he has
plans for i think it's the same fans that actually
helped organize the justice league comic con event
earlier this summer the one before dc fandom when
he revealed all that new black suit superman
footage from the justice league snyder cut
during that live stream he revealed a bunch of
really cool details and plans that he had for
future stories like a sequel to the justice league
snyder cut full-blown sequel coming back and doing
more movies with his version of darkseid who's
played by ray porter he also explained what's
going on with his version of catwoman in the dc
eu what her story was with ben affleck's version
of batman during the justice league snyder cuts
storyline he talked about doing a new batman movie
with ben affleck's version of batman that i'll
explain in a second and he even dunked on some
fans that had been dunking on him in the past not
in a malicious way just joking about the hot takes
that random internet people had on his movies one
of my favorite things about zack snyder is his
connection to the fans he probably interacts with
the fans in a much better way in a much closer
way than any other big studio movie director
that you've seen the last five or six years
there are a lot of big directors that are active
on twitter facebook social but zack snyder takes
it a step further you're not going to see people
like christopher nolan going on fans podcasts
or anything like that like christopher nolan
makes amazing movies made one of the best batman
trilogies of all time the dark knight trilogy but
he's famous amongst online press for historically
not giving them the time of day so we'll talk
about the justice league snyder cut sequel stuff
zack snyder explained earlier then i'll talk about
the batman movie stuff and the catwoman stuff
so what he said about justice league 2 was it's
a fair question to ask me you know like what do
i say to the world about you know what happens
when darkseid comes to earth then what is that
a thing and i think listen the truth is did i
write that did i conceive and have a complete
do i know what happens when darkseid comes yes i
know what happens to say and to speculate about
what that is and what that would be is exciting
so what zack snyder is saying is that he has a
script for the justice league snyder cut 2
movie which is based on his original plans
for what justice league 2 would have been had the
studio not cancelled the movie a couple years ago
as he says it would have been mostly about
what happens when dark site comes to earth
finally there is dark side in the justice league
snyder cut a bunch of new dark side coming back in
but not nearly as much dark side as you would have
gotten in the justice league sequel we do know a
lot about how the story of that sequel would have
played out though with the character arcs for
batman superman wonder woman flash green lantern
cyborg aquaman the rest star because he told us
a couple years ago back when no one thought that
we'd ever have a chance to see it way before the
snyder cut ever became a thing there are some
minor changes that would have to be made to
that just because of the new stuff that he's now
adding back in with the additional photography
for the justice league snyder cut but the sequel
is kind of a time travel movie using the flash
the movie starts out in the original timeline
we'll call that the batman nightmare timeline
you see some of that in the justice league snyder
cut trailer from earlier this year this scene here
panning across the rubble and the artifacts in
the hall of justice and the omega symbol burned
into the ground in that timeline darkseid came to
earth and was able to defeat the justice league
pretty handily by taking superman out of the
equation before he became a threat in order to
do that darkseid wound up killing lois lane and is
then able to enslave superman using the anti-life
equation that's right he was totally going to
do the anti-life equation in the sequels that's
how you get to the evil looking superman and the
pair demons all wearing his symbol on their armor
most of the justice league and the rest of earth's
heroes are killed batman eventually dies too only
flash cyborg maybe some green lanterns wind up
surviving and using cyborg's mother box tech to
make the calculations necessary to help flash time
travel back in time to warn batman that pays off
the scene from batman v superman where he warns
him to save lois lane save lois she's the key
that starts the new timeline where they're
able to prevent superman from succumbing to
the anti-life equation and the justice league is
able to team up with hal jordan green lantern in
the green lantern corps defeating darkseid they
kind of did a version of that during the justice
league apocalypse war movie where darkseid spanks
the justice league pretty easily enslaves most of
earth's population turning it into a glorified
mining colony and then the flash has to pull
another flash point to prevent it from ever coming
to pass in the animated movies that was meant to
bring things back around to the original justice
league flashpoint movie like here we go again
obviously they haven't done flashpoint in the
dceu live action movies yet but that is part of
the inspiration for the upcoming flash movie with
both ben affleck's batman and michael keaton's
batman zack snyder isn't really involved with that
beyond maybe getting a producer credit like he has
a producer credit on wonder woman 1984 because
of his earlier contract for the dc eu movies
but i don't think he actually had any creative
input for wonder woman 1984. issues that they're
continuing in those movies with characters that
he established so i think that's why he gets a
producer credit but the version of flashpoint
that they're doing for the flash movie will
be different from the comics they're also doing
the multiverse story to help connect all the new
movies that are coming up with the old movies
that have come before even the super deep cut
movies like the christopher reeve superman films
that's how you get to your michael keaton batman
from the tim burton movies but talking about more
batman stuff with ben affleck the other new movie
zack snyder revealed that he's trying to have made
is a full-blown batman dark knight returns movie
live action movie that is so it will be something
that happens within the dc eu that's connected to
all the other movies the way we found out about
this was when zack snyder was reacting to other
fans old comments calling batman v superman a dark
knight returns movie because even though the plot
is very different part of that movie was inspired
by the story of frank miller's dark knight returns
comic book if you've never seen it they released
two animated dark knight returns movies they broke
the story into two parts so it's like a three hour
total movie all together but the animated movie is
basically them just doing the comic book story if
you've never read that story it's sort of like an
alternate timeline version of gotham set during
1986 but in that retro future it's a very old
version of batman who comes out of retirement to
fight opposing forces in the gotham city police
department the us government and then fight
superman himself who's kind of turned into
a puppet for the president so it's sort of like
batman versus the system so to speak trying to
tear down the system of oppression in the country
the similarities to batman v superman are in
that during the dark knight returns just like ben
affleck's batman during batman v superman he gave
up being batman after jason todd's death 10 years
prior and once batman gave up being batman crime
exploded overnight runs rampant all over gotham
city but eventually just like ben affleck's batman
dark knight returns batman is reminded of why
he became batman and don the cape and cow in
the first place that inspires him to take the
mantle back up and then he sets about cleaning
up gotham city going around but he's super
hardcore he starts killing a bunch of criminals
so the president orders superman to basically
arrest batman and that's what sets off the batman
versus superman of it all zack snyder didn't say
how close he was to getting a live action dartnik
returns movie made but if that ever happens of
course i'll make videos for it it would be huge
i think right now it's just a never say never
situation like it could happen in the future
and i think a lot of it just depends on how
things proceed with the next couple of dc movies
and how the justice league snyder cut performs
but think about it this way if we're talking
about an old man version of ben affleck's batman
think about what's happening with michael keaton's
batman right now like the batman beyond version
of michael keaton's batman really old coming back
they could totally do that in another 10 years
with ben affleck's batman if he's down for it
in number one probably one of the biggest things
talking about his version of catwoman and what
her story was in the dc eu so obviously we have
the new robert pattinson batman movies we have
the new zoe kravitz version of catwoman but that's
meant to be something separate and its own little
bubble of continuity zack snyder explained
who ben affleck's version of catwoman was
he revealed it was carla gujino his quote was
probably i would say carlos catwoman is perfect
you would have to say there's a flashback to 10
years ago where they were a thing then he had
to arrest her i don't know what happened or he had
to let her go and it tweaked him and now who knows
what she's doing now she's running around in some
sort of international antiquities or something
and he needs to retire and they find each other
so that's him basically saying that ben affleck's
batman after the events of justice league he's
getting older catwoman has been locked up in
arkham this whole time through the dc movies that
we've seen ben affleck in and eventually they find
each other again and their romance rekindles
but there's no confirmation that he added any
catwoman scenes to the snyder cut because he's
filming all these new scenes he is adding all this
joker stuff with jared leto's version of the joker
and we think that that's flashbacks for the scenes
of robin dying but everyone let me know in the
comments which would you rather see zack snyder do
a new version of justice league 2 or would
you rather see him do a batman dark knight
returns movie with ben affleck someday my next
big video will be for the mandalorian season 2
episode 3 that'll post friday as long as you
have alerts enabled for my channel you should
see that when i post it while you wait for
everything speaking of justice league reunions
click here for my witcher season 2 teaser trailer
video and to learn about jason momoa joining henry
cavill in the witcher universe and click here
for my full mandalorian season 2 episode 2 video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!